[Music]
anonymous you've probably heard of them
they're the group of online activists
that carry out cyber apps to advance
social and political change and
sometimes they need a lawyer a really
good lawyer
at first glance J Lederman seems like a
regular guy he lives in the suburbs
drives a fast car and has a
self-professed deadhead oh and he loves
whiskey
but there's more to J story that
immediately meets the eye when Jason's
down at the computer he's anything but
average
I represent accused cyber criminals many
of whom are either affiliated with
Anonymous or closely related groups and
it all started with a tweet I sent out a
couple tweets giving it attention to the
fact that I would take a pro bono case
the next morning there was an email in
my inbox from commander axe commander X
a prominent member of the hacktivist
group Anonymous commander X was the
first activist I represented once he
felt that I was his lawyer he determined
unilaterally that I was the lawyer for
anonymous there are a number of
encrypted chat type programs that I
would prefer to use I like to keep the
NSA guessing with which method of
communication I'm going to use with the
idea that perhaps they can't monitor
them all at once
when someone contacts me and I do not
know who they are it's the most
beautiful but with purest form of
conversation because there is absolutely
no judgment on anything over the
computer everyone's equal one of the
hardest things about representing
anonymous just working around digital
laws that were written decades ago his
main gripe is with the CFAA the Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act the penalties are
outrageous it's a bad law it's a broken
law it's not something that fit
with today's technology sharing your
Netflix password with your friends that
could be a federal crime I hope that by
helping activists by pursuing these
cases in the courts by continuing to
keep the issues alive in the media that
we can enact some degree of change I
hope it's not just a few of us crazies
running through the wilderness
[Music]
I'm the first exoneree to be exonerated
by an Innocence Project and then go on
to be a lawyer for an Innocence Project
the best thing to do with your anger is
to use it as the fuel that drives you to
reach goals in life my name is Jared
Adams and this is my story at the age of
seventeen I was sentenced to 28 years in
a maximum-security prison I was falsely
accused of a sexual assault I didn't
commit and I realized very quickly early
on it had nothing to do with the truth
it was about race if you can't afford to
prove your innocence or the court
affords an attorney to you my lawyer
convinced my family and I that a no
defense theory was the best theory of
defense it was a horrible idea and that
defense contributed to me being found
guilty I was incarcerated in prison so I
was there for almost a decade one day is
too long when you're innocent I was a
kid I was absolutely terrified my entire
youth was gone this is when boys become
men I missed out on all of that
I was at the time broken but when I
continued to see that my mother and my
aunts weren't broken and they were
fighting for of my innocence I decided
that if I didn't have the energy to
fight for myself I most certainly could
find the energy to fight for them I
started to try to grasp the law I would
get law books law journals and read
about attorneys who were litigating
cases in the state of Wisconsin so I
reached out to the Innocence Project the
organization that advocates and
litigates on behalf of the wrongfully
convicted ultimately they accepted my
case the court unanimously decided to
overturn my conviction I ended up
enrolling in a 4-year College where I
studied criminal justice after
graduating I obtained my law degree and
I became an attorney I had the
opportunity to exonerate another person
and it was special to me because it was
in the same state in which I was
wrongfully convicted I've now opened my
own law practice and I think that me
coming from a place like the criminal
justice system being wronged hearing the
stories and getting to know other men
who have been wronged
what better advocate could they have but
myself I strongly feel like this
happened to me for a reason it was
necessary to encourage the greatness out
of me
[Music]
if you're associated with hip-hop and
you happen to be african-american and
you're seeing with the same group of
people there is this tendency to just
assume you for some reason are
considered part of gang activity and I
really feel like they're targets it's
got to the point now if there is a
hip-hop artist that's charged with a
crime anywhere in the United States I'm
gonna get a phone call I've been in this
criminal defense space for more than
three decades as my practice built up I
would occasionally represent somebody
famous I was fortunate enough to
represent Dennis Rodman safe Evans
Shaquille O'Neal and that eventually I
represented a guy named rate Rick Davis
to me he's range of Davis to the rest of
the world he's humane school
getting him out on bond against all odds
it's getting him early released as that
was happening everybody else started
calling up one of the turning points for
me on many levels was dealing with the
case involving amigos in south Georgia
amigos came in and they perform and law
enforcement went after them and they
went into their bus and they said there
were weeds and guns and bla bla bla but
law enforcement admittedly on the stand
said we went into their social media and
we saw all these things and we were
waiting for that law enforcement they're
just going to assume what they see in
YouTube and what they say an Instagram
is associated with criminal conduct and
they're gonna go out of their way to try
to take you down there are issues that
we have to contend with with the case
involving amigos we assembled 14 15
lawyers we have record labels behind us
we have somebody flying in from a record
label in Manhattan to testify but then
what about somebody in Greenville
Mississippi what about somebody in Enid
Oklahoma what about people of color in
those communities that don't have the
money to bring in a legal team and don't
have record label standing behind them
and it really catalyzed my interest in
addressing racism and our criminal
justice system and mass incarceration I
figure while I'm up and about I can at
least do something to fight this system
[Music]
a lot of my clients and their family
members live in a constant state of fear
30 years ago I mean there were very
little deportation cases and now that is
the bulk of cases that we take many of
the cases go through the Stewart
Detention Center
and a lot of attorneys don't take
Stewart cases I really worry that if I
were not in some of my clients life that
they would be in a very difficult
situation
I do what I do because I am an immigrant
I know how they feel I know what their
family members are going through and I
would hate for someone not to have the
proper representation because I know
that I'm really their last hope I was
born in the Dominican Republic and that
twelve years old
my family and I moved to the United
States we moved to New York and then we
moved to Georgia I went on to Georgia
State University and then I got a chance
to work at an immigration law firm as a
receptionist and it was really a
blessing because my uncle was picked up
by eyes
you know we never thought that that
would be possible because we came here
with a green card wise ice picking my
uncle up why is he at Stewart Detention
Center when he's not here illegally he
was detained for almost a year until we
were finally able to win the removal
case and it was at that moment I knew
that I wanted to become an immigration
attorney so how are you I'm scared I'm
really scared I'm not gonna lie I'm
scared to be in this place and I'm
scared to to go back to my country
Honduras is not a place where you can
leave freely you know now if you came
and I know for sure that if I appeal
again it will take longer as well you
know and it's probably gonna be another
year yeah I understand this is a very
serious serious decision that you have
to make a horse as a lawyer I always
want to keep fighting we never it really
give up but it is at the expense of your
freedom I would like to say that I would
like to fight because I know that you
have done everything is possible and I
and like I told you before I'm so
grateful to have you as my lawyer
[Music]
we do a lot of these cases pro bono and
we have 1500 active cases
[Music]
the majority of my clients have lived
here for decades they have built a life
here they pay taxes they have children
here and they have lived crime free
lives and then they get pulled over for
traffic violations and you know that's
how they end up in ice detention
[Music]
so in order for me to visit a client at
Stewart normally I have to get up at 4
a.m.
it's far away it takes us about three
hours one way to get there
and for years Stewart had the highest
deportation rate in the country
[Music]
it's in the middle of nowhere cold and
isolated and just very difficult to get
access to it's difficult to get access
to the client it's difficult for media
to get access it has a horrible
reputation
[Music]
I hear from my clients all the time
about the mistreatment these individuals
deserve that their cases be heard before
a judge so I have to fight for them and
I have to give them their day in court
and and they're grateful for that that's
what they want
[Music]
I've had many cases where my clients
come in and they said I've met with five
attorneys and they told me that nothing
could be done and we have been able to
win their case that's really why I do
what I do why I don't take no for an
answer if a client is willing to allow
me to fight their case I will fight the
case to the end lion tkinter is Sally
Sally poor Katie no way nevado y por que
alguien agora su casa no tenemos
direction awooga lo tanto el gobierno
Rajoy a de alguien from Ella penal a
trabajado fuerte mint a mi casa para
puede sacar des Infierno and estaba e yo
al Burma yeah mi casa perdido nothing
creo que el caso Asik in control avada
Penelope na dou Y ratios are AOS toiya
Kiev where hakuna familia in will
I just I I really wish that the
immigration debate could be more focused
on the actual people
[Music]
I mean I represent surgeons nurses
teachers who are just here trying to
provide for a better life
it's really a privilege and it's really
a blessing to do what I do I get
strength from the cases that we are able
to win it definitely brings great joy to
my life because I know I've made a
difference
[Music]
[Music]
you